à l'occasion de l'anniversaire de la
disparition de dessiner alors que vient
de sortir le dernier astérix évocation
de celui qui a créé les uns
irréductibles gaulois mais aussi via
d'autres personnages comme utile vu quiz
nos goûts de nicolas le marine et
frédéric faure vincent kelner il était
une fois un petit garçon qui aimait
faire rire
ainsi commence l'histoire de rené
goscinny une enfance en argentine dans
les années 30 des parents qui
encouragent leurs fils dans sa vocation
ce sera le dessin la caricature à new
york en 1952 goscinny participe à la
naissance du magazine mad fernandel par
exemple ça c'est re signer sa note au
port de l'autre côté de l'atlantique le
jeune marcel gotlib lit alors le
magazine sans savoir que quelques années
plus tard il travaillera avec goscinny
ils créeront les dingodossiers donnait
pas l'impression du glac 10è minute
c'est moi scénario c'est moi vous vous
faites ce que je vous dit de faire
on travaillait quand même en
collaboration ou toujours astérix lucky
luke
iznogoud et tant d'autres dans les
années 60 et 70
rené goscinny va inventer de nombreuses
histoires pour tous ces personnages
derrière sa machine à écrire
il y avait un air gourmand comme s'il
avait une serviette autour du cou etc
est la place de la machine il y avait un
plat délicieux à manger scénario rené
goscinny fait toujours rigoler
rené goscinny paris 16e rené goscinny le
scénariste de paris que la seine-et-oise
nous envie depuis 1977 la machine à
écrire et silencieuse
rené goscinny n'est plus mais il a
marqué des générations de lecteurs pour
la plus grande fierté de sa fille anne
rarement se passe une journée sans qu'on
entende d'un homme politique sans citer
personne
il est tombé dedans quand il était petit
ou c'est dommage il avait pas de potion
magique
une balade dans les rues incognito rené
goscinny est toujours resté proche du
public un public qui a su le lui rendre
25 ans après sa disparition le
scénariste continue de faire rire des
millions de grands enfants
c'est